le rouge et l'orange ces deux couleurs
sont désormais familières mais si
angoissantes pour les habitants du pas
de-Calais mes premiers mots iront donc
vers les sinistrés des deux tempêtes et
des inondations qui se prolongent depuis
3 semaines je pense aux habitants
sinistrés bien trop nombreux ils n'ont
plus de maison ils n'ont plus de
vêtements ni de chaussures et leur
regard est vide car désespéré tout comme
leur mère qui malgré leur courages sont
épuisés et à bout de solution je pense
au sinistrés agricoles qui n'ont plus de
champ à se mais plus de bêtes à faire
pâurer plus de légumes à récolter je
pense au sinistr économiqu qui ne
peuvent plus faire fonctionner leurs
entreprises ni faire travailler leurs
salariés jamais nous n'avons connu
catastrophe d'une telle ampleur avec une
étendue géographique si importante
jamais nous n'avons autant souhaité la
solidarité locale et nationale pour
venir effacer le désespoir d'un avenir
sombre encore à découvrir au-delà de la
solidarité des collectivités locales qui
est déjà précisée et qui va s'accroître
au-delà de la solidarité nationale qui
est pleinement assurée dans l'urgence
par nos préfets et leurs services la
représentation nationale et les
collectivités attend des précisions pour
le futur de ces sinistrés nous avons
aussi besoin d'une solidarité européenne
comme je l'ai dit au président de la
République hier je souhaite que l'on
puisse d'ors et déjà activer les trois
mécanismes de soutien européen le
premier mécanisme qui est celui de la
protection civile de l'Union européenne
le deuxième est le fond de solidarité de
l'Union européenne qui peut être activé
pour des catastrophes régionales et
enfin l'instrument d'aide d'urgence j'ai
deux questions pouvez-vous nous préciser
les dispositions nationales qui seront
prises par le gouvernement et nous
préciser si l'Union européenne est déjà
sollicité dans la gestion de cette
catastrophe
naturel